here's the kind of question you will get
and the question is how do you phrase
this recurring decimal as a fraction
just as a point of interest right if you
remember this from like you're eight
when you first meet them or recurring
decimals
no matter how long it takes them to
recur or recurring decimals and all
terminating decimals they're all
fractions
every single one right if it doesn't
recur and it doesn't terminate it's not
a fraction it's irrational and the most
common examples are there to serve the
normal PI a and so on but I'm anything
in this form that are pits you can write
as a decimal does anyone know what this
particular ones equal to now that's the
answer but how do you get it now
there's a couple of ways I'm going to
show you we'll deal again with recurring
decimals when we meet series and
sequences in 12 but there's a fairly
simple way that you can argue this out
using algebra okay so he's the way that
you would said that you would begin by
saying let this thing that you've been
given well let's give it a name so that
we can work with it okay so if X is
equal to zero point two repeater that's
equal to it
Sarris your a point two two so on okay
so that's another way of writing the
same thing it's rather less efficient
but it's helpful to me because my next
step is to say well I want to work with
this thing and be able to do some you
know division order right so in order to
compare this to something that's helpful
I'm just going to multiply it by ten
right now the reason why I lots of
moment n necessitates me writing it out
like this is because all you need to do
to multiply ten his move a desolate
place so you need to do so if I multiply
this I'll get two point two two two and
they're all there because there's an
infinite number of them okay so now
what's helpful here is that if I say
okay this line - this slide they're
almost exactly the same right can you
see in
right there's this thing and this thing
which are identical okay so if I call
this I mean you don't have to I'm just
doing this for your own illustration if
I say line to take away line 1 10 X
minus X all right I'm going to have to
point to doctor dot take away zero point
two dot dot and all I'm left with is
well nine X on this side this side okay
all right this well I'll refer back to
this I mean the real problem is this
this is the real problem that's the real
problem like if I say something is equal
to you know like if it really goes on
forever so this is we're getting in an
issue now excuse me I can say right that
there's an infinite number of twos
trailing off on the infinite the subtle
problem with that is that infinity is
not a number right it's it's an idea
it's a concept that it goes on forever I
could say there are 102 s or a million
twos but to say there's an infinite
number of two's it's a bit of a misnomer
what does it really mean
if the nines go on forever right well
let me put it to you in another way
right if I had say the number one and I
said to you what is the difference if I
take away this from this if I say this
minus this what would your answer be
right now but you have to justify that
right now the reason why I can't say
it's zero point one or zero point zero
zero one or zero point zero is is get
this just like these nines go on forever
in my solution these zeros are going to
go on forever you might say ah but there
will be a one at the end
there's no end it goes on forever
that's what forever means okay so be
that the zeros go on forever this number
over here is 0 so this is equal to this
okay now we have problems with that
because symbolically it looks wrong
because you're like what this is zero
point something and this is not zero
point something but that's you right at
the cusp of where notation right starts
to break down what something actually
means it's kind of a special case which
might explain well I mean look to gets
it to get to this result it's just as
easy for me to start with a nine
everywhere that there is a two written
here and you will come out quite clearly
with X is equal one because there we no
no no yes right so so I can argue it
that way but people still like it's
because of the way does it mix it's
completely about the way it looks right
yes 0.9 rapido is one and there are
other ways I can argue it but I think
that's sufficient